bonsoir nouvelle semaine pour le 7 8
nous sommes en direct si vous nous
rejoignez à 18h en ce 5 novembre et nous
allons parler de la présidentielle
américaine j - avant le scrutin comment
les ressortissants américains qui vivent
dans les Yvelines vivent cette campagne
justement ce duel entre Barack Obama et
mitromaine nous posons la question à
deux d'entre eux qui sont déjà sur ce
plateau également sur ce plateau
Thibault Fleury grave spécialiste de la
Constitution américaine maître de
conférence à l'Université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines il nous
donnera aussi son éclairage et puis nous
tenterons à de répondre à cette question
pourquoi à cette élection passionne tant
les Français nous sommes lundi comme
chaque lundi et le point sur le sport
c'est avec Anthony Reij bonsoir Anthony
salut Wilfried au programme ce soir au
programme tout d'abord la le début de la
chronique avec la réaction exclusive du
tout nouveau champion d'Europe d'apnée
Xavier Delpy que j'avais eu la chance de
suivre pendant sa préparation il a été
sacré dans la catégorie jump blue et il
a obtenu le nouveau record du monde de
cette épreuve et puis nous resterons
dans l'eau avec le tir subaquatique le
club de plongée la palme plaisir ouest
le club de plaisir organise son
traditionnel trophée le trophée 500 ce
week-end l'occasion de découvrir ses
disciplines et puis comme d'habitude en
fin de chronique les résultats tout en
images tous les résultats sports la
chronique le sport donc à suivre pour
débuter cette édition du 5 novembre nous
allons d'abord faire le point sur le
logement l'hébergement d'urgence le
logement d'accueil d'urgence sans
attendre la baisse des températures le
préfet des Yvelines a décidé d'ouvrir
296 places d'hébergement supplémentaires
dans le département c'est 40% de plus
que l'an passé reportage
reportage à suivre avant de parler sur
ce plateau dans un instant toujours en
direct si vous nous suivez à 18h de ces
élections américaines vues depuis le
département des Yvelines est-ce que le
sujet est prêt alors on regarde ce les
grands froids ne sont pas encore
installés mais le Premier ministre
Jean-Marc Ayrault le premier novembre au
lendemain de la trêve hivernale c'est
voulu claire la politique ne se base pas
sur les thermomètres en conséquence il
faut des centres d'accueil ouvert toute
l'année plus de place d'hébergement et
pas seulement quand les températures
sont négatives du coup la préfecture des
Yvelines a activé dès ce week-end le
dispositif hivernal d'urgence
296 places supplémentaires ouvertes soit
une augmentation de 39% par rapport à la
dernière campagne d'urgence une
mobilisation hivernale qui vient
compléter le dispositif permanent
d'accueil et d'hébergement qui comptent
plus de 1118 places pérenne ouverte donc
toute l'année outre ce dispositif le 115
le numéro d'urgence se voit doté de
quatre personnes en plus le SAMU va
augmenter ses maraude et des
travailleurs sociaux supplémentaires
seront recrutés car la problématique est
globale et implacable pas d'emploi pas
de logement
élections américaines J-1 le républicain
mythei défi donc le démocrate baraque
Obama plus de 200 millions d'électeurs
qui vont devoir les départager ce
scrutin s'annonce plutôt serré sur ce
plateau Thibault Fleury grave donc
bonsoir à vous spécialiste de la
Constitution américaine maître de
conférence en droit public à
l'université de Versailles 50 ans en
Yvelines et puis également de
ressortissants américains sur ce plateau
installé dans le département des
Yvelines qui vont nous accompagner
durant la prochaine demi-heure et les
abbets eux Debourg bonsoir à vous et
William stuncan Duncan Williams plutôt
merci d'avoir répondu tous les deux à
notre invitation on va débuter par un
chiffre c'est le chiffre de cette
édition 48% 48% c'est le chiffre que
voilà c'est le résultat donc qui
pourrait sortir des urnes le verdict des
urnes lors de cette élection 48% pour
les deux candidats de candidats à
égalité une égalité presque presque
parfaite vous y croyez
ça peut toujours arriver mais c'est
rarement arrivé je crois que c'est
arrivé une fois dans l'histoire
américaine au début du XIXe siècle
pourquoi pas après le chiffre de 48% est
un peu annoncé c'est plutôt en termes de
grands électeurs qu'il faudrait qu'il
faudrait considérer les choses le risque
qui est une égalité de 269 électeurs et
de ce point de vue là l'égalité est
c'est plus certain on comprend mieux
qu'il y a une possibilité d'égalité
parce que si les grands électeurs sont à
égalité dans ce cas il y a un vrai
risque effectivement que les deux
candidats soient à égalité et dans ces
cas là c'est à égalité parfaite alors
dans ces cas-là évidemment la
Constitution a prévu le a prévu le cas
c'est la house of représentative ce qui
va élire qui va voter pour le président
et c'est le Sénat qui va voter pour le
vice-président ce qui pourrait arriver à
quelque chose de tout à fait incroyable
une cohabitation à l'américaine avec
Miss from me élu parce que là où ça flop
présentatives est républicaine et un
vice-président Joe Biden démocrate parce
que Sénat et démocrate qui n'est jamais
arrivé dans l'histoire américaine
alors du côté des ressortissants
américains sur ces derniers sondages 48%
à peu près même s'il faut le nuancer en
termes de grands électeurs ça vous
surprend déjà en tout cas de voir que
les deux candidats se sont autant à
égalité pas du tout effectivement de
payer assez divisé depuis un certain
temps on a déjà vu avec l'élection 2000
encore une fois en 2004 ou le
CE cgué sur le Rayo plutôt qu'en Floride
mais c'était sensiblement similaire et
donc on voit toujours la fameuse carte
ou des deux côtes en bleu ils sont deux
pays en rouge il faut nous lancer un peu
plus que ça mais le pays est quand même
divisé depuis un certain temps vous
ressentez cette division également même
si vous vivez aujourd'hui en France dans
le département des Yvelines mais vous
sentez cette division du pays cette
division de la communauté américaine
absolument je pense que c'était surtout
jouait au niveau des conventions on a vu
en septembre
très bien suivi aux Etats-Unis ainsi que
il y avait une division très forte santé
au niveau de citoyen et c'est presque
dommage je dirais de voir cette division
tellement forte aux États-Unis pourquoi
dommage
parce que je pense que depuis 20 ans le
pays se diviser davantage
et ça c'est pas positif pour pour gérer
le pays il faut une collaboration même
si on a pas quelqu'un dans la Maison
Blanche et les démocrates dans le
travail ensemble pour avancer
les idées donc si on a été visé on passe
le temps de se débattre et pas avancer
le pays on va peut-être prendre le temps
tout de même d'expliquer ce système
électoral américain 213 millions
d'électeurs qui doivent se prononcer en
fait pour des grands électeurs vous
l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure mais c'est
comme ça que le système marche c'est
très différent du système français
totalement c'est pas du tout une
élection au système au suffrage
universel direct comme on en a
l'habitude en France les les citoyens
américains ne votent pas pour
Barack Obama ou pour metformine il vote
pour des grands électeurs alors en
pratique ils savent évidemment pour qui
le grand électeur qu'ils Élise va voter
mais il n'empêche que ça permet une
représentation au niveau des États donc
c'est au niveau des États que que tout
se joue pour la présidentielle
américaine c'est un peu comme le système
pour les sénatoriales en France s'il
fallait le comparer à quelque chose que
les Français peuvent déjà connaître oui
c'est un peu comme les sénatoriales
peut-être que l'exemple qui viendrait le
mieux en tête ce serait d'imaginer que
la même chose se passerait au niveau de
l'Europe et alors peut-être qu'on
comprendrait les choses comme si les
Français votaient pour des grands
électeurs français les Allemands pour
des grands électeurs allemands et
qu'ensuite ces grands électeurs allaient
voter pour un président de l'Union
européenne là on a une image qui serait
peut-être parlante et ce qu'il faut
rajouter pour bien comprendre c'est que
dans une état 51% de votre populaire
passe pour un candidat et il recrute
100% des grands électeurs donc ça fausse
qu'on peut vendre on va dire de calcul
la traduction du vote populaire en
et vous le déplorez justement le fait
que ça fausse un petit peu l'expression
du suffrage
de l'époque où seuls les propriét
leur universel les électeurs ont jusqu'à
21h pour voter la grande inconnue aussi
c'est l'abstention en France c'est
souvent un élément déterminant on fait
très attention à l'abstention est-ce
qu'aux États-Unis aussi l'abstention est
un facteur important est-ce que ça va
jouer sur ce scrutin ça peut toujours
évident jouer on sait que chacun des
candidats fait des normes des marches
pour pour inciter les gens à s'inscrire
sur les listes électorales notamment
Barack Obama auprès des jeunes alors ça
peut plutôt jouer justement pour le
président sortant c'est lui qui va faire
plus attention à l'abstention parce que
j'imagine que du côté de dogsiders
forcément de de me mettre on va plutôt
chercher justement à se mobiliser donc
on craint moins l'abstention oui tout à
fait tout à fait ceci étant dit on a vu
des images je crois que c'était je sais
plus dans il y a certains États où les
ou les bureaux de vote ont déjà ouvert
ou est déjà possible de voter un des
grands enjeux d'ailleurs aussi de cette
présidentielle et on a vu des files
d'attente immenses alors je sais pas
exactement quels sont les prévisions
pour l'abstention mais bon évidemment
l'abstention peut toujours avoir un sur
une élections historiquement Saturne
entre 50 et 55% de de
mobilisation mais chacun doit mobiliser
c'est son noyau dur de soutien que soit
droite ou à gauche sinon l'élection va
se jouer sur sur quelques centaines de
milliers de voix peut-être dans certains
états vous avez voté déjà parce qu'à
l'étranger on vote par correspondance
c'est bien ça vous avez voté tous les
deux oui est-ce qu'on peut dire pour qui
vous avez voté vous préférez pas le dire
moi je supporte Obama et moi aussi les
Américains ont le porte on le porte sur
sur l'extérieur c'est pas comment en
France chacun dit pour qu'ils soutient
les amis sur facebook qui mettent ce qui
s'est passé
on va juste faire une petite pause et
nous sommes allés demander aux
yvelinesois s'il comprenait ce système
électoral américain on va voir si
ensuite les explications que vous avez
pu apporter sur splatoon vous savez il y
a quelque chose
un système à deux niveaux pas suffrage
universel
c'est les grands électeurs qui décident
en fait moi je suis depuis de nombreuses
années dans les toutes dernières
semaines effectivement après ça joue
comme la plupart de ce qui se passe en
France pour les élections ça joue
beaucoup à l'image pas grand chose avec
les votes anticipées les États et tout
pas grand chose ça m'intéresse pas
vraiment du coup c'est un peu plus
compliqué que enfin c'est peut-être plus
simple pour eux mais pour nous ça peut
plus compliqué pour l'instant on a que
deux candidats donc le choix est plus
vite fait quoi c'est plus simple mais
disons que avant d'arriver à ces deux
candidats bon c'est pas comment ils
arrivent là quoi j'ai même pas suivi
alors je risque pas de comprendre et ça
se fait effectivement par État à chaque
État effectivement demande un certain
nombre d'électeurs et les électeurs qui
effectivement sont le plus représentatif
au niveau de l'État c'est un état
supplémentaire pour pour le futur
candidat voilà et après ça se fait pas
au nombre de voix ça se fait par étape
par état gagné ah bah non notre question
avec ça depuis deux mois je pense qu'ils
ont mieux à faire que ce qu'ils sont en
train de faire actuellement et le
système j'y comprends rien
mais tout l'argent qui sont en train de
mettre dans leur dans leurs élections
ils devraient le mettre par exemple pour
le cyclone qui s'est passé là
dernièrement ce serait peut-être plus
judicieux voilà
deux candidats comme on arrive à deux
candidats on a entendu tout à l'heure
c'est bien il y a que deux candidats
c'est plus facile comme ça de se
prononcer mais comme on arrive à deux
candidats tout le monde arrive à deux
candidats c'est un système qui est qui
est bi partisan qui fonctionne comme ça
avec deux grandes oppositions qui vient
aussi du fait qu'à l'origine on avait
une opposition entre fédéraliste et anti
fédéralisme donc ça c'est tout de suite
structuré autour de de groupe comme ça
et ensuite c'est chaque partie qui au
sein de ses conventions primaires
ensuite il y a des primaires ça dépend
encore des États mais il y a des
primaires et qui qui vont choisir leur
candidat c'est quelque chose qui
surprend toujours beaucoup en France
parce qu'évidemment on est habitué à
notre petite dizaine de candidats
minimum donc le débat est structuré très
rapidement autour des deux grands partis
autre sujet Comment vous suivez cette
campagne depuis la France quelles sont
les médias que vous suivez vous suivez
les médias américains sur place ou
est-ce que vous suivez les médias
français parce qu'on en parle aussi
beaucoup en France de cette élection
pour moi c'est un peu les deux mais
surtout de presse américaine j'avoue
aussi cet été j'avais la chance d'être
aux États-Unis pendant
le repas
en direct ça c'est impressionnant
l'Internet a beaucoup facilité la chose
il faut dire mais c'est vrai que j'aime
bien le regard d'après France française
bien que on voit qu'elle copie un peu
les articles du New York Times ou autre
ça arrive mais c'est bien de voir cette
point de vue objectif ou par exemple
Courrier international où on voit
comment le monde voit notre pays c'est
vraiment c'est une expérience formidable
de voir comment on est perçu dans le
monde et puis comparer justement la
presse dans les deux pays est-ce que du
côté français il y a on est plus
partisans aussi peut-être est-ce qu'il y
a l'effet Obama se voit dans la presse
aussi par exemple oh la presse est
partisans partout c'est peut-être c'est
peut-être mieux caché enfin mieux cacher
aux États-Unis mais c'est vrai que la
presse française est assez partisan
c'est vrai mais
enfin ils ont peut-être raison
d'ailleurs
forcément on le disait tout à l'heure
puisqu'on parle des médias nous sommes
allés voir l'un de vos collègues de
l'Université de Versailles Saint-Quentin
Thibault Fleury graff c'est Christian
Delporte spécialiste de l'histoire
contemporaine spécialiste des médias des
questions de communication voici déjà
son point de vue sur l'importance de la
télévision aux États-Unis aux États-Unis
c'est en grande partie les médias qui
font l'élection et notamment la
télévision
je pense que plus que beaucoup d'autres
scrutin de ce type les débats ont joué à
rôle important et notamment le premier
débat qui a
recrédibilisé ramener et du coup
donne à quelques jours du scrutin des
rapports extrêmement étroit sur le plan
des sondages aux États-Unis ce sont les
médias qui font l'élection
c'est vrai
d'une certaine point de vue c'est vrai
que c'est très très présent aux
États-Unis dans la maison type il y a
plusieurs télévisions qui sont
et il y a sans cesse
c'est beaucoup plus qu'en France ou le
temps est vraiment
mesuré
que ça dure depuis plus de deux ans et
donc les Américains
pour un président en exercice passez à
faire campagne en fait
c'est très très long
ce qui a changé depuis que moi j'habite
en France depuis 8 ans maintenant et
maintenant qu'il y a plus de
restrictions sur des publicités que les
sociétés peuvent mettre autant d'argent
qui veulent en fait dans les États qui
te sont en jeu il y a bombarder par
publicité en permanence et ce depuis
presque pour le candidat comme si on
vendait de la lessive un petit peu
aujourd'hui c'est un petit peu ça le
candidat qui va vous permettre de sauver
le pays c'est comme ça que c'est vendu
parce que même dans la Constitution rien
de prévoit une égalité de traitement
entre les candidats non non
voilà pour être très clair en fonction
de son fonctionnement
plus il peut acheter de publicité il y a
quelque chose de ration qui était qui
était souligné à l'instant dans le petit
reportage c'est que finalement le débat
a fait remonter revenir dans les
sondages ce qui finalement montre que
bon on peut dépasser on peut dépenser
des millions de dollars en publicité un
bon vrai débat avec deux candidats qui
discutent de leurs idées au moins de
certaines d'entre elles peut encore
changer la changer la donne malgré ça
derrière il y a pas de financement de
l'État pour les partis politiques ça ne
fonctionne pas comme ça aux États-Unis
non c'est très différent effectivement
c'est en fonction des soutiens et on
comprend pourquoi chaque candidat
cherche des soutiens de personnalité qui
se multiplient ces derniers jours
d'ailleurs puisque l'élection ce sera
dans la nuit de mardi un mercredi en
France on va continuer à parler de ces
élections on va s'intéresser aux médias
aussi du côté de la France voir comment
les Français suivent cette campagne on a
demandé aux yvelinois le regard sur ce
scrutin un regard relativement
intéressant oui oui surtout ça va être
ça va se jouer à très peu de voix très
très peu de voix je pense que Obama va
passer je souhaite que le président
Obama passe bah c'est toujours une
chanson de savoir ce qui se passe autour
de soi il y a pas de
on ne vit pas que sur tout maintenant
avec avec l'Europe avec les frontières
ouvertes et tout bon c'est quand même
intéressant de savoir ce qui se passe
aussi en Amérique quoi c'est vrai que
l'Amérique est quand même un grand pays
quoi en américaines ils ont tous les
deux des tas de choses formidables mais
moi je suis plus pour Obama parce que
j'aime pas l'autre c'est un homme qui
est pas sérieux et qui est un petit peu
malhonnête Obama souhaite une Europe en
bonne santé pour conduire lui-même une
économie prospère sur le plan
international j'en ai aucun et
franchement c'est très loin comme les
américains ont la même sensation
vis-à-vis de nous je suis très attentive
parce que
mitrenait me fait peur et donc
j'aimerais mieux je préférerais Obama il
est plus au niveau diplomatique je
préfère les moins guerriers le regard
d'une européenne qui espère que ce soit
Mama qui passe
c'est à dire je pense qu'au niveau de
l'Europe ce serait mieux que ce soit
Obama
les Yvelinois les Français enfin en tout
cas les cinq continents les Yvelines
soutiennent Obama c'est surprenant de
voir qu'en tout cas ils ont une regard
un point de vue sur cette élection
américaine est-ce qu'aux États-Unis on a
le même regard sur ce qui se passe en
France pendant le scrutin des
présidentielles en France
que je constate puis les 20 ans que je
suis en France les Français sont très
curieux de ce qui se passe au-delà de la
frontière et ça je salue à tout moment
alors les Américains sont très
nombreuses
on sait qu'on est important dans la vie
du monde et malheureusement au niveau de
langue étrangères au niveau de curiosité
les Américaines cherche pas parce que ce
qui se passe
et pour vous pourquoi le scrutin
patiente autant les Français
faut dire que les États-Unis c'est un
peu le leader du monde en ce moment on
sait pas combien de temps ça va durer
mais depuis en fin de la chute de
l'Union soviétique ça reste quand même
le pays on va dire de plus important au
monde et et donc quelques uniquement
militairement etc et comme on a vu en
2000 personnes pensaient que ça comptait
on disait bouche gore c'est la même
c'est même personnage mais on voit la
différence que ça fait avec laquelle on
ira les démocrates n'auraient jamais
fait ça je pense donc on voit que ça
peut influer la vie sur de des
populations partout au monde c'est ça
c'est l'impact que ça peut avoir au-delà
des frontières américaines c'est ce qui
explique cet engouement selon vous je
suis d'accord j'ajouterai aussi que les
États-Unis restent une modèle de
démocratie que tous les pays
démocratiques dans le monde regarde avec
un curiosité pour pouvoir comment les
Américaines traitent des sujets
extrêmement importants comme les
élections donc je pense que c'est pas
juste cette élection mais de toute
manière c'est une fascination
pour les pays même et mes gens qui sont
tous nouveaux
pays que un homme issu de l'immigration
africaine peut devenir président de pays
en tant que spécialiste de cette
Constitution américaine et de ses droits
ce système de vote américain qui séduit
au-delà des frontières des États-Unis il
y a la fascination pour la pour la
démocratie comme vous le soulignez après
est-ce que elle est vraiment prégnante
dans l'intérêt peut-être dans l'intérêt
de des grands médias français oui après
pour le peuple français en général je
sais pas mais du coup je vais plutôt de
votre côté c'est à dire Obama le
charismatique Obama enfin on est
impressionné par Obama comment pas être
impressionné par quelqu'un comme ça qui
a l'air tout le temps si à l'aise qu'il
faut le voir ce sont mes correspond
beaucoup plus à l'homme politique dont
on a l'habitude il y a sa crainte il
paraît beaucoup plus formel il a sa
cravate et Obama il est président de la
première puissance du monde et on le
voit manche retroussé des cravates avec
une cravate mais aussi des cravates
pour les présidentielles dans les années
60 à faire c'est qui s'est fait lui-même
de rêve américain quelque part avant de
conclure ce plateau consacré aux
élections américaines vu depuis le
département des Yvelines nous allons
donner la parole une dernière fois à
Christian Delporte ce spécialiser médias
de l'Université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin lui aussi pense que lobba
Mania y est pour beaucoup dans cet
intérêt des Français dans ce scrutin
phénomène très particulier en France
c'est Loba Mania qui continue la BBC a
fait un sondage montrant que la France
était le pays le plus au bas maniaque de
la terre pratiquement en tout cas ça a
été fait auprès de 21 pays le moins
favorable à Obama c'est le Pakistan mais
la France de manière assez incroyable
continue à croire à Obama jusqu'au
dernier moment et ça ça transgresse
d'ailleurs les clivages habituels entre
la droite et la gauche puisque 75% des
gens de gauche choisissent Obama plutôt
cramener et 65% des gens de droite
choisissent également Obama alors
l'intérêt pour cette élection poursuit
finalement ce que l'on a vu déjà en 2008
avec cette particularité c'est qu'en
2008 on se disait est-ce qu'on va
pouvoir élire aux Etats-Unis un
président noir aujourd'hui les résultats
des sondages sont extrêmement serrées et
donc ça donne effectivement un regain
intérêt à cette élection
quand on regarde ce qui se passe dans
les journaux mais quand on regarde
également ce qui se passe sur internet
sur les réseaux sociaux on s'aperçoit
d'un véritable intérêt pour cette
élection et on s'aperçoit d'ailleurs que
l'on s'échange les derniers résultats
des sondages à la fois au niveau
national ce qui relativement peu
significatif aux États-Unis mais
également au niveau des États qui a là
une importance beaucoup plus
considérable et puisque ce professeur à
l'université évoquait la question de ce
soutien Obama qui dépasse les partis
politiques droites gauche on peut aussi
rappeler comment regaino qui est
l'ancienne plume de Nicolas Sarkozy
député UMP des Yvelines a dit qu'il
voterait Obama sans conviction mais
qu'il voterait plutôt Obama que mitrener
donc ça dépasse effectivement ce clivage
gauche-droite en France une toute
dernière question il y aura le scrutin
donc le 6 novembre et ensuite puisqu'on
va voter ils vont voter ses américains
pour des grands électeurs et ensuite les
grands électeurs vont se réunir je crois
que c'est début décembre et ensuite le
président sera officiellement élu et
entrera en fonction courant janvier pour
être précis c'est 17 décembre j'ai
trouvé la date et ce sera le 20 janvier
vous serez vous dans la nuit de mardi à
mercredi pendant les élections vous
allez suivre les médias
je change de faire le nuit blanche
j'ai arrêté en 2004
avant 8h du matin donc je me couche
tranquillement et vous vous serez debout
de bonheur pour suivre ça oui je vais
faire des faux mais je pense qu'on sera
vers midi en France enfin c'est
merci à tous les deux d'être venu donc
sur ce plateau partagez vos impressions
vous qui suivez cette campagne en tant
qu'Américain depuis le département des
Yvelines et puis merci aussi antibo
Fleury grave donc de l'Université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin d'être venu
nous apporter votre éclairage sur cette
Constitution américaine bien différente
dans le mode de fonctionnement de ce qui
se passe en France merci donc à tous les
trois la suite du 7 8 de ce 5 novembre
toujours réalisé en direct entre 18 et
19h c'est avec la page sport d'Antony
Reich mais avant le sport le point sur
ce week-end prolongé sans catastrophe
sur les routes des Yvelines les
contrôles se sont multipliées vous avez
sans doute aperçu les gendarmes sur les
bords des routes Catherine dulato fait
le point
un vrai temps de tout ça de la pluie du
vent et un risque à creux d'accident
pour ce week-end prolonger les forces de
l'ordre se sont montrées dans le
département dans les airs avec la
présence visible de l'hélicoptère de la
gendarmerie ou sur les routes avec les
voitures de patrouille comme ici aux
abords du péage de Saint-Arnoult le
weekend de la Toussaint est un weekend
traditionnellement fortement
accidentogène pourquoi parce que c'est
un long week-end donc il y a déjà
beaucoup de beaucoup de flux beaucoup de
chassés croisés sur les routes d'autre
part et je crois qu'aujourd'hui ça le
montre bien la météo n'est pas clémente
donc il y a beaucoup plus de risques et
des risques sont là donc il nous faut
être beaucoup plus présent et vigilant
les forces de l'ordre sont là évidemment
je me rappelle pour sanctionner quand tu
le faut les conducteurs qui ont une
conduite dangereuse ou non conforme au
code de la route mais ils sont là aussi
pour se montrer et puis pour faire de la
prévention ce week-end les forces de
l'ordre ont sanctionner les excès de
vitesse mais également les comportements
dangereux comme les dépassements par la
droite et les distances de sécurité non
respectées
une voiture banalisée circulait parmi le
flot de véhicules depuis le début de
l'année 38 morts ont été enregistrés sur
les routes des Yvelines avec un lourd
tribu à la fois essentiellement
d'ailleurs des des deux roues puisque
40% des accidents sont avec des deux
roues qui sont en cause ou victimes pour
cette opération qui a duré 3 heures 23
infractions ont été relevées dont 13
concernait des dépassements de vitesse
et pour les gendarmes le week-end a été
positif dans leur zone d'intervention
aucun accident enregistré pendant ce
temps de la Toussaint